hi Bob morning Kelly but tulips look
great have you ever wondered how your
dog experiences the world here's what
she sees not terribly interesting but
what she smells that's a totally
different story and it begins at her
wonderfully developed nose as your dog
catches the first hints of fresh air her
nose is moist spongy outside helps
capture any sense the breeze carries the
ability to smell separately with each
nostril spelling in stereo helps to
determine the direction of the smells
source so that within the first few
moments of sniffing the dog starts to
become aware of not just what kinds of
things are out there but also where
they're located as air enters the nose a
small fold of tissue divides it into two
separate folds one for breathing and one
just for smelling the second airflow
enters a region filled with highly
specialized olfactory receptor cells
several hundred millions of them
compared to our five million and unlike
our clumsy way of breathing in and out
through the same passage dogs exhale
through slits at the side of their nose
creating swirls of air that help draw in
new odor molecules and allow odor
concentration to build up over multiple
sniffs
but all that impressive nasal
architecture wouldn't be much help
without something to process the loads
of information the nose scoops up and it
turns out that the olfactory system
dedicated to processing smells takes up
many times more relative brain area in
dogs than in humans all of this allows
dogs to distinguish and remember a
staggering variety of specific sense at
concentrations up to 100 million times
less than what our noses can detect if
you can smell a spritz of perfume in a
small room a dog would have no trouble
smelling it in an enclosed Stadium and
distinguishing its ingredients to boot
and everything in the street every
passing person or car any contents of
the neighbors trash each type of tree
and all the birds and insects in it has
a distinct odor profile telling your dog
what it is where it is in which
direction it's moving in besides being
much more powerful than ours a dogs
sense of smell can pick up things that
can't even be seen at all a whole
separate olfactory system called the
vomeronasal organ above the roof of the
mouth detects the hormones all animals
including humans naturally release it
lets dogs identify potential mates or
distinguish between friendly and hostile
animals it alerts them to our various
emotional states and it can even tell
them when someone is pregnant or sick
because olfaction is more primal than
other senses bypassing the thalamus to
connect directly to their brain
structures involving emotion and
instinct we might even say a dog's
perception is more immediate and
visceral than ours but the most amazing
thing about your dog's nose is that it
can traverse time the past appears in
tracks left by passers-by and by the
warmth of a recently parked car or the
residue of where you've been and what
you've done recently landmarks like fire
hydrants and trees are aromatic bulletin
boards carrying messages of who's been
by what they've been eating and how
they're feeling and the future is in the
breeze alerting them to something or
someone approaching long before you see
them where we see and hear something at
a single moment a dog smells an entire
story from start to finish
in some of the best examples of canine
human collaboration dogs help us by
sharing and reacting to those stories
they can respond with kindness to people
in distress or with aggression to
threats because stress and anger
manifest as a cloud of hormones
recognizable to the dog's nose with the
proper training they can even alert us
to invisible threats ranging from bombs
to cancer as it turns out humanity's
best friend is not one who experiences
the same things we do but one who's
incredible knows reveals a whole other
world beyond our eyes
you